[Music]
and you're a genius your brain is almost
as perfect as your face Oh Ann Ann is
the greatest human being ever invented
you beautiful tropical fish you're smart
as a whip and you're cool under pressure
you've resuscitated a human heart in
your bare hands no I haven't you haven't
no you will you're that good of a nurse
Oh Ann I always forget because you're so
pretty you're not used to rejection and
you Remo infuse space unicorn man you
poetic noble land mermaid you're right
once again nobody can match your ethnic
hybrid energy and you beautiful sassy
mannequin come to life you beautiful
spinster I will find you love what did
you see something love you and you
opalescent tree shark sweet and
beautiful Ann has never been dumped
before with sexy nurse Ann Perkins
no you're thoughtful and you're
brilliant and your ambiguous ethnic
blend perfectly represents the dream of
the American melting pot you look like a
cartoon princess you're so beautiful I
mean you're always beautiful but right
now you are the most beautiful glowing
sun goddess ever and you're such a good
friend you're a beautiful talented
brilliant powerful musk ox Thank You ox
for keeping this ship afloat you got it
you